hello grammarians hello rosie hi paige
so in this video we're going to talk
about complex sentences we've talked in
another video about simple and compound
sentences so that is like
one independent clause or two
independent clauses
and with a complex sentence we're going
to introduce something called a
dependent clause
so a sentence needs at least one
independent clause to function as a
sentence
but with complex we're going to add this
dependent clause
so rosie what's an example of a complex
sentence
when we buy his birthday cake
we have to make sure it's lemon
so the sentence when we buy his birthday
cake we have to make sure it's lemon is
made up of two clauses and i've written
them in different colors here
so
the second one the pink one can stand on
its own as a sentence we could just say
we have to make sure it's lemon
it works it functions as as an
independent clause it's its own sentence
we have some information that might be
missing from this sentence because we
don't necessarily know what it's is
but
we do have all the components of an
independent clause here we've got
we've got a subject we
and a verb half
have to and well we have multiple verbs
yeah got a lot of have to make sure so
the the sentence is relying on some
information that's not provided but it
does still
stand as as its own sentence right like
we could have a sentence before it
that's like
we're gonna go buy a birthday cake we
have to make sure it's lemon right those
can be two separate sentences
in this case we have
this other
clause this what's called a dependent
clause we can't just say when we buy his
birthday cake as a sentence that doesn't
really
stand on its own it doesn't convey the
information that a sentence needs to
needs to convey
so we could have an independent clause
or a sentence
that's just we buy his birthday cake
it's kind of a weird
construction i don't know that
i would say that you could maybe say we
are buying his birthday cake
right but we buy his birthday cake still
works as a sentence it has a subject we
and a verb by
and
it expresses a complete idea it's
it's an action that's happening and it
tells you who's doing it
but we add this thing called a
subordinating conjunction that's this
word when here and that makes
this into a dependent clause it can't be
a sentence by itself
so it depends
on the later clause we have to make sure
it's lemon
to be part of a sentence
okay so rosie what's another example of
a complex sentence
although our tent was zipped up
the sound of hyenas in the distance
still frightened us
so again this sentence starts with a
dependent clause although our tent was
zipped up this would be independent if
it said our tent was zipped up but again
we have this subordinating conjunction
although at the beginning
and there's kind of a whole bunch of
different subordinating conjunctions
they're sort of just something that you
need to remember
but
essentially their job is
to
connect clauses in sentences but also
make things interdependent clauses
one other thing we we're showing you two
sentences where the dependent clause is
coming before the independent clause but
that's not necessarily
always going to be the case like for
example
we could have said the sound of hyenas
in the distance frightened us
even though
our tent was zipped up right that would
still be a complex sentence it would be
an independent clause and a dependent
clause but just in a different order
they don't have to be
in this order that we've
that we've done twice
okay so rosie what if i do something
like this like
when we buy his birthday cake we have to
make sure it's lemon because it's his
favorite i think because it's his
favorite is a dependent clause right
that's right and this sentence still
completely works as a complex sentence
because you still just have this one
independent clause we have to make sure
it's lemon but the thing about complex
sentences is you can add
more than one dependent clause if you
want and it's still considered a complex
sentence okay so it has to have just one
independent clause right but i guess as
many dependent clauses as you want yeah
you can go crazy okay cool
so i think that's that's complex
sentences it's an independent clause
that can be a sentence by itself
and one or more dependent clauses which
can't be sentences by themselves all put
together in one big sentence does that
sound right rosie sounds good to me
paige cool you can learn anything page
out rosie out